Castlerock is finally here and with it a
ton of mystery so in the series we're
gonna delve into each episode and unlock
some of the secrets that lay ahead the
first episode begins in the winter of
1991 near what will later learn are the
bluffs near Castle Lake here we see
Allan Pangborn the town sheriff load a
gun while listening to the radio the
radio is important as it announces the
mysterious disappearance of a small boy
Henry Deaver using a stick Pangborn
checks the surrounding snow for a body
he stops when he finds something only to
be relieved when it's just a dead deer a
deer that can also be found on the
Castle Rock town emblem while stopping
to rest a mysterious sound alerts
Pangborn to me it sounds similar to the
noises found in lost which by the way
was also produced by bad robot the
production company involved with Castle
Rock after the sound subsides Pangborn
is shocked to see Henry alive in the
middle of the frozen lake how he got
there we don't know but the lake seems
to hold some mysterious power
fast-forward 27 years to the summer of
2018 here we meet Dale Lacey and his
wife some might miss it but it's
important to note here that Dale's wife
is blind this will become significant
near the later part of the episode which
I'll reveal at the end of this video
Dale kisses his wife goodbye and we
learned this is supposed to be his last
day of work before retirement but the
day doesn't go where we think it's going
as Dale has other plans around Castle
Lake the same Lake from the beginning
and those plans involves suicide by
decapitation the title of the pilot is
called severance a double entendre
referring to the six-figure severance
Dale is to receive and the severed head
he is about to as well before Dale hits
the gas he's interrupted by a dog now I
think that this dog is actually a
figment of his imagination its
significance we don't quite know yet but
the lake seems to have the ability to
conjure memories or figments of the
imagination which will find occurs again
later on
shortly after Dale hits the gas is
killed and it's revealed he works for
Shawshank Correctional Facility the same
prison in Stephen King's Rita Hayworth
and the Shawshank Redemption this image
transitions us to the real Shawshank
where we meet the new warden
officer Chesterton gives a brief nod -
Shawshank by telling her this is where
warden Norton shot himself you'll
remember him from the movie Shawshank
Rives the wardens number two tells her
that Dale Lacey's head was never
recovered while she moves an ashtray
myself - a small detail that will be
revealed later in the episode officers
Zaleski and boy go to visit abandoned
cellblock F which hasn't been opened the
Christmas barn 87 an event we may see in
future episodes sulesky ventures further
by himself eventually stumbling upon a
hole in the ground
he travels further to find a notepad a
bucket of cigarettes and a book before
the big reveal of Bill scars scars
character who on IMDB is simply known as
the Shawshank prisoner but on the
Internet the kid so for the purposes of
the series all refer to him as the kid
until further notice
we get a quick look at his eyes which
are an odd mix of blue and amber but the
important thing to note here is that the
notepad Zaleski picks up and the book
are never seen again
it'll be interesting to see if they make
an appearance in future episodes in the
next scene the kid is questioned by
Chesterton on his mysterious appearance
the fly here can also be seen in
Zaleski's coffee later on in the episode
the kid is unusually afraid when the
fingerprint machine clicks is he afraid
of sudden noises or has he never seen
this technology before possibly hinting
he's not from this time or place
the warden inspects the cigarette butts
found in the water tank and compares
them to those of former warden Dale
Lacey both of them are Marlboros when
interrogating the kid the warden asked
him who he is to which he responds Henry
Mathieu Eva will get to know Henry
Deaver in the next scene where we see
the adult Deaver defending Lee Ann
chambers in a Texas courthouse Lee Ann
is the wife of Richard chambers who you
may remember as one of the antagonists
and stand by me she's on death row for
supposedly killing him
Deaver loses the case and while Leeanne
is having her last meal she asks him
what his earliest memory is we flashback
to penguin rushing young Deaver through
the forest she then has a cryptic
conversation about the afterlife
comparing it to a tape being erased and
consequently not being yourself anymore
kind of like when Pangborn put the tape
into the cassette player and
Henry who is not the same and whose
memory was erased the idea of memory
loss is found in several characters in
this episode including the kid Henry and
Henry's mother Ruth who will get to know
soon back in the flashback Pangburn is
amazed to find young Henry's hands
aren't reeled with frostbite for being
in the negative 40 degree force for 11
days wherever he was was it the same
place as the kid a place where time
stands still or a different world
entirely Zaleski looks at Henry Devers
file while pouring coffee for the warden
we learned that the town believes
Henry's disappearance was supposedly a
prank by Henry himself resulting in the
death of his father who has found frozen
to death with his back broken for those
interested the axe here's the same type
as used by Jack Torrance in The Shining
Deever gets a call from Zaleski telling
him to come to Shawshank to see the
mysterious kid who called him by name
you can see the odd directorial choice
to frame him in front of a noose
perhaps foreshadowing a throwback to
Dale lacy or both back in Castle Rock
were introduced to Molly strand who
purchases unknown drugs from a local
high schooler what therefore we'll have
to find out on her way home molly
watches as Henry gets off the bus the
same type of bus that red uses in the
Shawshank Redemption it's clear from her
reaction she doesn't want him to see her
and that there is some mysterious pass
between them on the way to his mother's
house Henry stops at his father's old
church and finds that the cemetery where
his father is buried is now a cement lot
this triggers a flashback of him telling
Pangborn he doesn't remember what
happened we also get a glimpse of a
mysterious white trinket the meaning of
which has yet to be revealed back at his
childhood home we meet Henry's mother
Ruth Deaver played by [ __ ] Spacek who
has Kari in De Palma's adaptation of
Stephen King's novel of the same name
she doesn't remember him and seems to
suffer from some sort of Alzheimer's or
dementia which explains the stove being
left on forgetting his name carrying the
icing salt in the summer and also
wearing a toque which could also be the
same two worn by him in 1991 we are now
introduced to older Alan Pangborn and it
seems there's a lot of tension between
him and Henry
Alan has been helping Ruth but Henry
suspects he's been leeching off of her
in the background a nature documentary
shows a snake killing a mouse which is
interesting
because the next scene with the kid in
prison features a mouse and mice are no
strangers to prisons in the Stephen King
universe if you recall mr. jingles in
the Green Mile and just like mr. jingles
this mouse faces a similar fate as it
seems the kid has some sort of power
which hence he may be able to control
animals telepathically Henry meets the
warden only to be given the cold
shoulder the warden says I wish I could
help you find your client mr. Deever
I can't very well call up a ghost which
the writers may be giving us a hint that
the kid is some sort of supernatural
being we also learned that Henry's
father used to visit the prison to
conduct Bible studies that links the
Devers with the prison and likely this
kid character and the warden has already
taken down the photos of the old warden
in the background in this scene where
Henry and Zaleski share look you can
make it mist over the prison walls even
though it's a completely sunny day at
home Henry notices a next door neighbor
watching him on this newspaper we see
the headline suicide at Shawshank which
i think is worded a bit weird since the
suicide didn't happen at Shawshank
rather at Castle Lake nowhere he did
Castle leg the bluff right where I found
you Henry tells Alan about his call from
Zaleski at Shawshank and we learn Alan
and Dale once knew each other Molly
takes out Henry's missing person poster
that apparently she saved along with a
plaid sweater these mementos including
the hourglass must have some
significance for her to keep them all
these years Henry goes to visit Dale
Lacey's makeshift memorial where he has
a vision of the winter and himself as a
kid could this mean he'll start
remembering what happened or that the
lake may hold visions for our characters
like the dog from the beginning we also
see a cross on a gravesite and one in
his home it's easy to assume that
Henry's father being a reverend that
religion will play a big role in
connecting a lot of these characters
Zaleski on security watch notices that
the kid has escaped from his cell and
that several the guards have been
brutally murdered a kid seemingly opens
the cell doors with his mind leading me
to believe that eight may have
telekinesis on par with that of Cary and
in the final scene we see that it was
Dale Lacey who kept the kid locked up
judging by the amount of cigarette butts
it was for some time but it begs the
question if the kid has powers how come
he didn't escape why now I
Dale has some power over the kid because
for half a second his eyes flicker this
little detail is easy to miss but here's
one of the most interesting finds if you
stop the video before Dale ventures up
the ladder you can make it what appears
to be an adjustable walking stick the
same used by the blind is there a
connection between the kid Dale and his
blind wife I guess we'll just have to
keep watching to find out thanks for
tuning in if you want more of these
episode breakdowns make sure to LIKE and
subscribe I'm really diggin the show and
I think it's only gonna get better leave
a comment below on the things I missed
and let's work together to solve the
mysteries of Castle Rock see you soon